all right everybody we are back with our
Barbie dream hour alongside Margot
Robbie
[Applause]
wreck she's excited I like it yes their
new movie is called Barbie and it's in
theaters July 21st Barbie is one of the
most popular dolls in history if not me
but there are so many other dolls that
we've known over the years as well it's
time to find out who remembers those
dolls best with a game called
doll of Fame
we're clever uh I'm over here all alone
without a teammate so Jocko come on
you're looking very Ken
[Music]
[Applause]
come on over teammates don't fail me I'm
just kidding uh Lord could you host this
game for us
[Music]
well absolutely Kelly you know me I'm
just a Barbie girl in a Barbie world
of my own creation you know Heaven up
here is just one giant dream boat play
set with a pool slide you're gonna love
it it's fantastic all right anyway let's
play a game here now uh in this game
every answer is a doll or a dolly now if
you know the answer you're going to hit
the button and Shout It Out
okay now if you're wrong you're going to
hear that and you don't get any second
guesses and the other team can steal
Kelly and Jaco you are playing to win a
prize for the middle of the audience
[Applause]
Make Some Noise there you go Margo and
Issa you are playing for the left side
Make Some Noise left side
[Applause]
and America and Kate are playing for the
right
I love you guys
that's beautiful bringing the nation
together okay here is your first
question okay here we go in this musical
Frank Sinatra had the horse right here
yes yes guys
okay come on now here we go here's the
next question this foul-moust red hair
doll might cut you with the knife
Chucky
it is Chucky not a clue not a clue not a
clue horror movie I don't watch horror
no thanks watch out here's the next
question to mix it up these dolls have
hair that stand straight up
it is trolls
all right this doll wrote some of the
best songs
[Laughter]
you like cut each other getting to the
button yeah we got so many rings yeah
America's competitive sure
next question
she was the wife of the fourth President
of the United States I love you no you
do Dolly Madison
[Music]
and I know dominant I just wouldn't have
done also tasty little mini donut the
Dolly Madison okay now that sound of
Barbie's Corvette getting ready to leave
means we have time for just one more
question as this is the final question
I'm going to make it worth five points
we could take it Five Points all right
this is it this is for the game the last
question
these dolls celebrated different eras of
us
[Applause]
I'm so glad you got that one right
we literally couldn't have planned that
better I would have been sad for you
I think of what America was like
of course everyone in our audience is a
winner because it's my show and that's
what happens if you don't know fun boy
they're a family company that makes
amazing pool floats for summer like the
ones you can see in Barbie's Corvette
fun boy just launched their official
Barbie the movie pool float collection
including the iconic bee inflatable pool
float and surfboard float they want you
to experience Barbie the movie in real
life so you're all getting a 200 gift
card to fun boy
[Applause]
which I am happy for thank you voice of
God
and thanks to the cast of Barbie
everybody
it's July 21st
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
guys I'm going home
[Music]